[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: OK, good morning.
So today, we're going to begin
our discussion of nitrogen
metabolism, which
is really going
to continue over the final
three lectures in the class.
Now, nitrogen, of course,
is critical for life.
You need nitrogen to make RNA
and DNA, as well as protein.
And so what we will see
is that as we discuss
the metabolism of amino acids,
and nucleic acids, not so
much how they contribute
to protein and RNA and DNA
but rather how they
interface with other pathways
and metabolism to lead to
how these molecules are
synthesized, how
they're broken down--
and what you will see as we
go through these discussions
is that understanding the
metabolism of these molecules
really is all about how
organisms handle nitrogen.
Now, of course, we've spent
much of the class talking
about how fat and sugar can
be oxidized as a way for cells
to get energy.
And of course, that's
very important.
A major role of fat and
sugar is energy transduction.
But of course, cells are
mostly made out of protein.
And so roughly 50% of a
cell by mass is protein.
And protein, therefore, is
a key part of our diets,
and really, any animal's diet
that eats other organisms.
So anything that's
nonphotosynthetic
has to be taking
in a lot of protein
because it's eating
other organisms in one
way or another.
Now, you will, of course,
know that nucleotides
are central for and the
heritability of life, and so
life couldn't exist, at
least in a heritable form,
without those.
And often, we equate
things like amino acids,
and nucleic-acid metabolism,
nitrogen metabolism as all
about energy and weight-lifting,
so weightlifters--
all the supplements that are
sold to help people get huge--
all of those things
usually involve
heavy loads of nitrogen-- so
creatine-- we talked about
that earlier in the course.
Leucine is a very common
weightlifting supplement.
These are all
nitrogen-containing compounds,
and it makes sense because if
we're going to build new mass
for cells, we certainly need
nitrogen to build the protein--
that's what half the cells are--
as well as the
nucleic acids that
enable cells to go on
and build new cells.
And in fact, roughly 50%, as
I said, of the mass of a cell
is protein, and another
10% is nucleic acid.
So really, a large chunk
of what our cells are
comes from these
nitrogen-containing compounds.
However may be something you
don't think about as much
is that we also, because we
have to eat other organisms,
consume a lot of
protein in our diet.
And therefore, protein
and particularly,
different amino
acids, also end up
being a very important nutrient.
And in fact, our
muscles and our liver
are storage organs, if
you will, for amino acids.
And so our muscles are always
getting bigger and smaller,
breaking down,
rebuilding each other
as we go through life as
they really participate
in our body's metabolism.
In fact, you have tons of energy
built up into your muscles.
And if you starve
yourself, stop eating,
you can live off of muscle
tissue for quite a lot of time.
And that is really using
the amino-acid breakdown
from our muscle tissue,
really, there as a way
to keep glucose
in our blood high
and keep our brain
thinking right.
That's why we talked last
time about the keto diet.
When we talked
about the keto diet,
remember, if you're going to
do this properly and really
be ketogenic, you can't
eat glucose, of course,
but you also can't
eat-- or carbohydrates.
But you also can't eat
protein, and the reason
is because the liver will
turn your amino acids back
into glucose.
And that's true whether
those amino acids come
from the diet or
those amino acids
can come from the
breakdown of muscle.
All right.
So if we use amino acids
as a source of energy
as a way to support
gluconeogenesis
to keep our carbohydrates
available for our brain,
we need a way to metabolize
those amino acids.
And if we metabolize
those amino acids,
we also then need a way to deal
with all the excess nitrogen.
And so, indeed, we already
introduced how this works.
And if you remember
back when we talked
about the malate-aspartate
shuttle, which you'll
recall was a way for us
to transfer electrons
from the cytosol
into the mitochondria
and involved this convoluted
swaps between aspartate,
and oxalacetate, and glutamate,
and alpha-ketoglutarate,
and at the time, we
introduced how amino acids are
related to alpha-keto acids.
And so I draw out how
oxalacetate, an amino acid,
is related to the
alpha-keto acid--
sorry-- how the amino
acid aspartame is related
to the alpha-keto
acid oxalacetate,
as well as how the
amino acid glutamate
is related to the amino
acid alpha-ketoglutarate.
Just to be very explicit remind
you what I meant for this,
and so here is the
amino acid alanine.
This is the amino acid alanine.
It is related to the
alpha-keto acid pyruvate.
And again the same relationship,
if you look back in your notes
when we discussed the
malate-aspartate shuttle--
glutamate to
alpha-ketoglutarate,
aspartate to oxalacetate.
Really, the keto group,
the alpha-keto group,
is being replaced
with the amino group.
And what should be clear to you
now is that if you can convert
an amino acid into
an alpha-keto acid--
that is dispose of the
nitrogen, get the ketone back--
it should be very
clear how you can then
oxidize pyruvate, oxidize
oxalacetate, oxidize
alpha-ketoglutarate-- as a
way to get energy directly,
burn it in the TCA cycle,
get ATP, NADH that way,
or turn it into glucose
by gluconeogenesis.
However, if we're
going to do this,
obviously, these nitrogenous
have to go somewhere.
And if you're going
to build amino acids,
those nitrogenous have
to come from somewhere.
And that's really why
the pathways that we're
going to discuss really, are
about nitrogen metabolism
and how cells deal with
either the excess nitrogen
from breaking down amino
acids and nucleic acids
or how cells obtain
that nitrogen as a way
to build these molecules.
Now, by way of introduction,
we have to discuss also,
where is it then that nitrogen,
for biological systems,
really comes from
in the first place?
Now this is almost never
an issue for animals,
and that's because we and other
animals eat other organisms.
And so we eat other
organisms-- usually,
we have a problem of dealing
with too much nitrogen.
However, for photosynthetic
organisms, how to get nitrogen
ends up being a real problem.
And so any of you who
have done any gardening
know that you need to add
fertilizer to your plants.
What is fertilizer?
Well, it's primarily
a source of nitrogen,
as well as phosphorus.
And really, it's the nitrogen
in the fertilizer that's
helping solve the
problem of where
the photosynthetic
organisms are going
to get the nitrogen
that they need to grow.
Now, of course, there's a lot
of nitrogen, nitrogen gas,
in our atmosphere, all right?
But nitrogen gas is
incredibly inert.
You use nitrogen
gas is an inert gas
to basically stop things that
are too reactive from reacting
with the air in the lab, OK?
Nitrogen gas as a
very stable molecule
is not at all useful to biology.
However, if we take this
nitrogen gas and we reduce it--
that is we add a
bunch of electrons--
what we end up with
now is we end up
with all of these
reduced nitrogen groups,
these amino groups that are
incredibly useful for biology.
These come up over
and over again.
These are the side chains
of our amino acids.
They're found on
all the cofactors.
They're forming
the hydrogen bonds
between our different
nucleosides, OK?
And so enzymes work.
Genetics happen.
Hydrogen bonds
form because of all
of these nitrogen-containing
compounds.
But you need a way to get
from this nitrogen gas
down to this reduced
nitrogen. And that is really,
so-called nitrogen
fixation, which is basically
taking nitrogen
gas and reducing it
to be a compound like
ammonia, which involves adding
electrons, that ends up
being one of the things,
the magic of biology, that
really makes life possible.
Now, you don't often think about
nitrogen fixation very much,
so obviously, we all
know that photosynthesis
is really central to
what makes life happen.
And we spent a lot of time
talking about photosynthesis.
Apart from
photosynthesis, which,
of course, takes the
energy from the Sun
and gives us a way
to get reduced carbon
that all life depends on--
nitrogen fixation is a
way to take nitrogen gas
from the atmosphere and turn
it into ammonia, a useful form
of nitrogen for life to use.
And what you may not realize
is nitrogen fixation really
only occurs in a select group
of prokaryotic organisms.
So these are really the
unsung heroes of life,
or at least the unsung
heroes of metabolism.
It's probably the most
central topic to life
that we're not going
to spend a lot of time
talking about in 705 simply
because we don't have time.
But it's basically redox
chemistry to take nitrogen gas,
add electrons to it, and end
up with reduced nitrogen.
This is very energy intensive--
requires on the order of 16 ATP
molecules.
It's covered well
in various textbooks
if you're interested in
reading about this further.
But I really want
you to appreciate
that this is something
that really has to happen,
and it's really
relatively few organisms
that allow this to happen for
all other life on the planet
to be dependent on.
This is really why
fertilizer ends up
being the thing that
you add to your garden.
So in the wild, nature would
set up symbiotic relationships
with other organisms, with
these nitrogen-fixing organisms,
in order to get the
nitrogen they can get.
However, we can help
that process along
by giving fertilizer.
If there's a lot of fertilizer
runoff, you get algae blooms.
That's really because
all this nitrogen now
gets dumped into the water.
That ends up being
rate-limiting, often,
for photosynthetic organisms,
like algae, to grow.
And so this ends up being
a really important topic
if you're interested in
environmental science
or if you're interested
in agriculture.
And it's at least
something I want
to make you aware of from
this introductory course.
All right.
Now, for most organisms, we
get, from either our diet
or from the environment,
fixed nitrogen.
And the two forms
of fixed nitrogen
that we need to discuss
is ammonia, as well as
the conjugate base of
ammonia, which is ammonium.
Now, fertilizer is, of
course, very rich in ammonia.
And animals that eat other
organisms get lots of nitrogen
from breakdown of proteins.
And that is a source of
ammonia or ammonium ions.
And so photosynthetic
organisms have
the problem of getting these.
Animals off and have the problem
of, how do we get rid of this?
Now, if you've ever
cleaned with ammonia,
you know that it's pretty nasty.
It smells bad.
It's a cleaning agent.
It's very toxic to
lots of organisms
at high enough levels.
And so animals really need
strategies-- or, all life,
really, cells need
strategies about how they're
going to handle and deal with
these nitrogen-containing
compounds, either to incorporate
it or to get rid of it.
Now, I'm going to spend a lot
of time today talking about how
animals who take in a lot of--
eat other organisms,
take in a lot of nitrogen
have to deal with
the nitrogen excess.
And it turns out that you can
deal with the ammonia that's
generated from the breakdown
of your amino acids
in lots of different ways.
And basically, there
is no one solution
that life uses that's
universal for how you deal
with the excess
nitrogen. Really,
different strategies
have been involved
incorporating the
metabolism of amino acids
and nucleic acids
that fit the lifestyle
of different creatures.
And so fish and
other aquatic life
really deals with nitrogen
because they can just
excrete ammonia directly.
They live in the ocean--
lots of excess space
into the ocean.
Just take the ammonia.
Send it off into the ocean.
The large volume of
water in the ocean
means dealing with ammonia
is not such a big problem--
literally pissing into
the ocean to get rid
of their excess ammonia,
their nitrogen waste.
Now, terrestrial animals--
I'll just say
terrestrial creatures--
have a different
problem to deal with.
And that is they can't tolerate
the high concentrations
of ammonia that would be
necessary to just release it
into the environment, so
they need another solution.
And of course, our solution is
to excrete our excess nitrogen
as urea.
So that's urea.
This is why we make urine.
And really, our solution to
eliminate excess nitrogen
is to concentrate that nitrogen,
rather than excreting it
as ammonia--
but to make urea, put
it into our urine,
and eliminate it
through urination.
Now, not all animals make urea.
Things like reptiles
and birds, which--
turns out making urea requires
access to lots of water.
Reptiles don't always have
They live in dry climates.
Birds don't want
to have to carry
around all the extra water
weight of dealing with urea.
So instead of urea, it
turns out that they excrete
their nitrogen as uric acid.
So what's uric acid?
So this here is uric acid.
So uric acid is
basically a purine.
So it should look very similar
to the adenine and guanine
rings that you saw
earlier in the class.
And so they basically
generate uric acid,
which allows them to excrete
more nitrogen with less water.
And so bird poop-- birds
don't urinate-- the bird poop
that you get, that
slurry of material,
is basically a mixture of
solid waste and uric acid.
And that's how birds eliminate
their waste all in one
go as a way to save
some water as they deal
with their excess nitrogen.
All right, the fact that
different terrestrial
creatures-- some, like us, make
urea-- some make uric acid--
really deals with,
shows that urea--
you will see today is from
amino-acid metabolism--
uric acid is, of
course, from purine,
from purine metabolism-- we'll
talk about that in the last
lecture of the course--
they really illustrate
how the metabolism
of amino acids and
nucleic acids is really
about the metabolism of nitrogen
and how these pathways are
really set up in a way that
allows exchange of ammonia
with amino acids, as well
as with nucleic acids,
as the nitrogen can
really flow between all
of these different
biological molecules.
And along the way,
well, this allows
a way to excrete nitrogen.
It also, obviously, involves
ways to incorporate it and
is really the pathway cells
use to both make and break
down these compounds.
All right.
Now, as humans,
we, of course, eat
a diet that's high in protein--
higher in protein.
Now the current fad is to
eat high-protein diets.
That's the latest
trend that's healthy.
And this involves lots
of nitrogen excess,
and so we have to,
as humans, urinate
several times a
day because we need
to excrete lots of nitrogen.
Now, that's really our
amount of urea out.
So that urea out,
really, in a healthy
person is balanced with the
nitrogen in from the diet?
Makes sense?
If we are not growing and we
eat a certain amount of protein,
if we eat more
protein, that means
we need to excrete
more nitrogen.
If we eat less protein, then we
need to excrete less nitrogen.
And so the nitrogen in and
out should be balanced.
Now the reality is that
not all of our nitrogen
is excreted as urea.
Some of it ends up in the
stool as other compounds.
And so for a healthy
person, nitrogen in
is greater than nitrogen
out in the urine, the urea.
Nitrogen is really
greater than nitrogen out.
And this is what is referred to
medically as positive nitrogen
balance.
So if I collect all of
your urine for 24 hours
and keep track of all the food
that you eat, and I measure
all the nitrogen in the unit
and all the nitrogen in the food
you eat, there's
going to be more taken
in than I measure
in the urine, that's
positive nitrogen balance.
And that is what is standard,
healthy for most humans.
Now, if there's positive
nitrogen balance,
it means you can also have
negative nitrogen balance,
which really means that
the amount of nitrogen
in is less than the
amount of nitrogen out.
That is you are losing
more nitrogen in the urine
than you're taking in.
Medically, this is
a very bad thing.
When does this occur?
Well, it occurs during
periods of starvation.
Make sense?
If you're not eating
any food, you still
need to get energy
from somewhere.
You'll catabolize your glycogen,
you'll catabolize your fat,
but you'll also catabolize the
amino acids in your muscle.
Those amino acids will generate
excess nitrogen, more nitrogen
out than you've
taken in the diet.
This also occurs
during some illnesses--
famously, cancer, AIDS, sepsis,
all of these really horrible
conditions that some people--
can be very life threatening.
Many of these lead to a
phenomenon known as cachexia.
So what's cachexia?
You waste away, lose all
of your lean body mass.
This is also basically a state
of negative nitrogen balance.
And why this is
really, a current topic
that lots of people are
trying to figure out.
But it's really a case
where you are breaking down
more of your muscle protein,
more amino acids, and losing
that nitrogen than
you're taking in.
And treatment of the
underlying condition
is really required for
this to get better.
All right.
Now, it turns out I
can experimentally
cause negative nitrogen
balance in an animal
if I remove certain amino
acids from your diet.
Why is that?
Well, it's because
prokaryotes, plants, yeast,
lots of organisms, many
organisms, can make all 20
of the amino acids that are
required to build protein.
But it turns out that
animals, including humans,
cannot make all 20 amino acids.
It's a quirk of our physiology.
But it turns out some of the
20 amino acids that are needed
to build protein are essential.
That is they have to come
from external sources.
So remember, there's
lots of vitamins
out there that we can't make.
We have to get
those from our diet.
There's essential lipids.
We talked about that
last time again--
have to get those from our diet.
And some of the amino acids
that we need to live also
have to come from
an external source.
And in the 1950s, experiments
actually done on humans,
on medical students,
actually found
that if you take these essential
amino acids out of the diet,
what happens is that you can
shift those medical students
into a state of negative
nitrogen balance.
And that's because they're
unable to synthesize protein.
You're always synthesizing
and breaking down protein.
If you don't have the essential
amino acids to resynthesize
your protein, you now
break down more protein
than you synthesize,
and you end up
with negative nitrogen balance.
So what are these
essential amino acids?
Well, I post them
here on this picture.
And so here's the
essential amino acid.
They have to be
obtained from nutrition.
Here's the non-essential
amino acid.
These can be obtained
from the outside,
but we also have the pathways
in order to make them.
If you count these
up, you will see
that there are nine
essential amino acids and 11
non-essential amino acids.
It turns out that two of the
non-essential amino acids
require essential
amino acids to make,
so they're sort of
conditionally essential.
From a trivia
standpoint, I guess,
the answer is that there's
nine essential amino acids,
and they are--
I'll use the one-letter
abbreviation.
So there's lysine, histidine,
isoleucine, leucine, valine,
threonine, tryptophan,
phenylalanine, and methionine.
Now, there's two other ones.
If you have enough
phenylalanine,
we can synthesize tyrosine.
And if you have
enough methionine,
we can synthesize cystine.
But it turns out that
tyrosine and cystine
because they require
phenylalanine and methionine,
for all intents and
purposes, are also essential.
So really, 11 of the 20 amino
acids come from our diet,
either directly or
indirectly in the case
of tyrosine and cystine.
Now, of course, our diets
involve lots of proteins.
We eat other animals,
and so rarely is it
an issue that we need these,
which is probably how evolution
was able to lose the
ability to make them,
because we take in lots of
amino acids all the time anyway.
And these are amino acids that
are primarily important only
for making proteins.
But this also really
illustrates that proteins
are a large reservoir of
the nitrogen we take in,
and we just take it in premade
already as these amino acids,
even though we can synthesize
the remaining nine.
All right, now of the
remaining nine amino acids--
these are the ones that
we can synthesize-- these
are really largely ones about
how we move nitrogen around
through biological systems.
We'll see that as we
go through the rest
of the lectures on
the pathways involving
amino-acid metabolism.
And where I want
to start with this
is how we're going to deal
with ammonia, which is really,
exchanged in and out of
the biological molecules,
mostly the two of the
remaining amino acids.
And those two are
glutamate and glutamine.
So I'll just remind you
because this is important--
E is the one-letter
abbreviation for glutamate.
Q is the one letter
abbreviation for glutamine.
And glutamate and
glutamine are really
central to exchanging ammonia
in and out of molecules.
Just to remind you
what these look like--
so this is the alpha-keto acid,
alpha-ketoglutarate, ketone,
alpha to the carboxylic
acid, alpha-keto acid,
alpha-ketoglutarate.
So remember, it differs from
the amino acid glutamate.
So exchange that alpha-keto
group for the amino group.
Now I have glutamate.
And glutamine is, rather
than carboxylic acid
on the side chain, you add
this second nitrogen group.
And so what you will see as
we go through the lectures,
that glutamate is really--
the major glutamate,
alpha-ketoglutarate
is really the major
nitrogen donor and acceptor
to get nitrogen in and
out of other amino acids.
In the last lecture,
you'll see that glutamine
is an important nitrogen donor.
This nitrogen on the
side chain ends up
being important for getting
nitrogen into nucleic acids.
Now, a really key enzyme
to getting these nitrogen
in and out is the one that
catalyzes this step right here.
This is catalyzed by an enzyme
called glutamate dehydrogenase.
And glutamate
dehydrogenase really
carries out the
following reaction.
There's alpha-ketoglutarate.
So this can pick up
an ammonia molecule.
OK.
So with this intermediate.
And now we have two electrons
here as a hydride ion,
which, of course, we're
donating two electrons.
That's why it's a dehydrogenase.
It Involves
nicotinamide cofactor.
So these can come from
either NADPH or NADH,
generating NAD+ or NADP+.
And so reduce this molecule--
oxidized NADH, or
NADPH, NAD+, or NADP--
and you get the
amino acid glutamate.
And so here's a
reaction catalyzed
by glutamate dehydrogenase
that can convert
the alpha-keto acid,
alpha-ketoglutarate,
into the amino acid glutamate.
This reaction, which
effectively is ammonia plus
alpha-ketoglutarate plus NADH
or NADPH can reversibility
generate glutamate plus
NAD+ or NADP+ plus water.
So this reaction, again,
glutamate dehydrogenase--
very reversible reaction--
can use either NADH, or NADP,
or NAD+, or NADP+.
Either factor works,
and it's a key reaction
to convert the alpha-keto
acid, alpha-ketoglutarate,
with the amino acid glutamate
and get ammonia in and out
of the amino-acid pool.
All right, so I
mentioned glutamine
is the other major
nitrogen carrier.
And so how is this made?
Well, you can make it.
So if you start with glutamate,
and you phosphorylate
that glutamate with ATP--
so that's now a phospho acid
on the side chain of glutamate.
Lose the inorganic
phosphate, and now we
end up with glutamine--
glutamine.
All right, this is
carried out by an enzyme
called glutamine synthase.
And it's basically another
way to pick up ammonia.
This process can be reversed.
So we can take glutamine.
So I'm going to draw
out the whole molecule.
I'll just draw here
the side chain.
So this here would be the
side chain of glutamine.
Can just use water to remove
the ammonia and regenerate
glutamate carried out by an
enzyme called glutaminase--
so glutamate to glutamine,
glutamine to glutamate--
glutamine synthase--
glutaminase.
Notice, just like any
other reaction or pathway
we talked about, one
direction is favorable.
The other direction is not.
So this direction requires
energy input for it to work.
ATP is used in
glutamine synthase.
Glutaminase doesn't require
ATP because it's favorable--
makes sense with all the
other stuff we talked about.
And so as animals, the way
our tissues deal with nitrogen
is that if we catabolize an
amino acid in our tissue,
we end up generating ammonia.
That ammonia ends up
either in glutamate
via the glutamate
hydrogenation reaction,
or it involves in glutamine.
And then we carry that nitrogen
as glutamate or glutamine
in our blood.
It gets transported to
our liver and kidneys,
and our liver and kidney
handle that excess nitrogen by,
in our case, turning
it into urea.
Other organisms might turn
it into something else
in specialized tissues,
where it can then
be excreted, all right?
And again, it also
ends up being that
glutamate-- if we're going
to make amino acids-- ends up
being a good source of nitrogen.
And glutamine, if we're going
to make nucleic
acids, end up being
a good source of nitrogen. And
so for catabolizing amino acids
for energy, we can
release ammonia
via the glutamate
dehydrogenase reaction moving
in this direction, or we
can incorporate ammonia
by running in the
opposite direction.
And so what you will see
then is that the synthesis
and breakdown, now
focusing on amino acids,
is really going to
involve exchanging
the nitrogen between alpha-keto
acids and amino acids
and glutamine and
glutamate as we
described for the
malate-aspartate shuttle, OK?
So let's just show
an example of that.
So this is what was involved in
the malate-aspartate shuttle.
OK, so here's oxalacetate.
So alpha ketone to the
acid-- so alpha-keto acid.
This here is the
amino acid aspartate.
Remember, in the
malate-aspartate shuttle,
we basically exchanged the
amino group and aspartate to be
glutamate and the alpha-keto
acid, oxalacetate,
for alpha-keto glutarate--
so alpha-keto acid, amino
acid, alpha-keto acid,
amino acid balanced
on both sides.
And nature can basically use
this system to now get nitrogen
in and out of systems, OK?
So take an amino acid alanine.
It's related to the
alpha-keto acid pyruvate.
You can exchange
that amino group
onto alpha-keto glutarate, OK?
That will generate glutamate.
You can use that glutamate.
Transfer the amino
group on to oxalacetate.
That can generate aspartate.
And so really, here, you have
a system where you can use
transfer of these amino acids
between alpha-keto glutarate
and glutamate and
really, any alpha--
or sorry-- any amino acid
and any alpha-keto acid, OK?
And so if we're going to
catabolize an amino acid, say,
alanine, give the nitrogen
to alpha-ketoglutarate,
now it ends up on
glutamate-- that glutamate
can go off in the blood.
It can be used elsewhere
to synthesize aspartate
from oxaloacetate or
some other amino acid
from some other alpha-keto acid.
Or you can just
stay on glutamate,
go here to the
glutamate-dehydrogenase
reaction and generate ammonia.
And so for catabolism
of amino acids,
the first step involves
transferring the nitrogen
to alpha-ketoglutarate, and that
generates glutamate, as well as
the alpha-keto acid, which
can then be metabolized.
If we're going to
make an amino acid,
we can start with
the alpha-keto acid
and transfer the
nitrogen from glutamate.
And that's a way, then,
to make the amino acid.
And so glutamate dehydrogenase
lets you get ammonia in and out
of the system, and then
this basically transferring
of nitrogen between
alpha-keto acids
and amino acids
involving glutamate and
alpha-ketoglutarate now
allows you to move nitrogen
around the system.
And so that's basically,
in a nutshell,
how you synthesize and
break down many amino acids,
although, of course,
there are some exceptions.
And so glutamine
we just described.
It's the glutamine synthase
and the glutaminase reaction.
Obviously, that's how you
synthesize and break down
glutamine relative to glutamate.
Asparagine is like glutamine.
Remember, asparagine--
also, it's
aspartate with an amino
group on the side chain,
just like glutamine.
And so its metabolism
is similar to glutamine.
Arginine-- arginine is
a special amino acid
with three nitrogen molecules.
We'll discuss that at
length in a little bit.
Prolene-- if you look up
the structure of prolene,
what you'll find is that it's
glutamate that's been cyclized,
then reduced.
And so prolene is also
a little bit different.
You make glutamate,
cyclize it, and reduce it.
That's how you get prolene.
And then glycine, it turns
out, is generated from serine.
And we'll discuss that at
length in the next lecture.
But for the other--
most of the other amino
acids, reactions really
involve interconversion
between the alpha-keto acid
and the amino acid and
glutamine-glutamate
via series of reactions
referred to as transamination.
OK and so
transamination is really
these reactions that allow
this swapping of nitrogen
between amino acids
and alpha-keto acids
and alpha-ketoglutarate
and glutamate.
Some of these are very famous.
Many of you want to
go to medical school.
You're going to do
liver-function tests, where you
measure levels of ALT and AST.
These are the liver-function
enzymes, or the transaminases,
all right?
They're basically
the transaminases
that catalyze the exchange
in the case of ALT
between alanine pyruvate and
glutamate alpha-ketoglutarate.
AST is the transaminase that
catalyzes the exchange between
aspartate oxalacetate and
glutamine alpha-ketoglutarate--
very active, highly
reversible enzymes,
very abundant in the liver.
The liver is important
to get nitrogen
in and out of across
different amino acids--
high levels in the liver cells--
so when the liver is damaged,
they leak out, and they
measure in the blood,
and that's a sign
of liver damage.
And so again, just to
drive this point home,
so you have alpha-ketoglutarate.
Alpha-ketoglutarate can
be converted to glutamate.
This is the
glutamate-dehydrogenase
reaction, so it involves a
redox step with NADH or NADPH.
That allows you to
interconvert the ammonia,
basically, take nitrogen in and
out of the system as ammonia.
And then once it's
in the system,
now you can do
transamination to move
the nitrogen between
glutamate alpha-ketoglutarate
with any other alpha-keto acid
and amino acid, all right?
And so if you're going
to catalyze amino acids,
you go in that direction.
And you're a fish--
you go this direction,
release it as ammonia.
Or you can come
in this direction,
and that is anabolism.
That allows you to build
amino acids, all right?
OK.
So these transamination
reactions then
become very important, and we
need to discuss how they work.
So Transamination itself
requires a cofactor.
This cofactor is called
pyridoxal phosphate, OK?
It's derived from a vitamin,
like many cofactors.
In this case, it's
vitamin B6, also referred
to as pyridoxine, vitamin B6.
Vitamin B6 looks like this.
OK, so that's pyridoxine.
That's vitamin B6.
Turns out we eat vitamin B6.
And the active form in
the cell is this molecule,
where this alcohol has been
oxidized to the aldehyde.
And this Coke factor is referred
to as pyridoxal phosphate
and abbreviated PLP,
for Pyridoxal Phosphate.
All right.
All right, now let's go over
now pyridoxal phosphate allows
these transamination
reactions to occur.
So let's start off here with
just some generic amino acid,
OK?
And so the transaminase has--
so here's pyridoxal phosphate.
I'm not going to draw the whole
molecule-- just a skeleton
of the pyridoxal phosphate.
So it reacts with
the amino acid.
OK?
So that's that middle
part here of the molecule.
OK?
Generate the shift base.
Just draw the top part here.
OK, so here now we generate
the alpha-keto acid.
And this alternative version
of pyridoxal phosphate called
pyridoxamine, which is
also abbreviated PMP--
and so basically, I've
exchanged the amino acid,
transferring the nitrogen
onto PLP to make PMP
and generating the
alpha-keto acid.
That PMP can now react with
some other alpha-keto acid.
So here's our PMP.
And basically, if I just reverse
all of those exact same steps
that I just did--
so I'll do, for the
sake of brevity here,
I'll do two steps in one.
OK, so I broke this up here
into two different steps before,
but to save me some drawing,
I'm just going to do one here.
And all I did is just
run the same mechanism
in the opposite direction.
And now I've taken
my alpha-keto acid,
got the nitrogen from PMP,
regenerated now a new amino
acid, as well as--
I'm not going to
draw it all out,
but regenerated
pyridoxal phosphate.
And so pyridoxal
phosphate ends up
being this really
useful cofactor that
enables this transamination
reaction that
is this interconversion
between an amino acid
and alpha-keto acid and another
amino acid or alpha-keto acid.
And so pyridoxal phosphate is
a co-factor that also useful
for other amino-acid-containing
reactions--
basically enables
this sort of chemistry
that enables nitrogen to--
to facilitate reactions
with amino acids.
We will see in the
next lecture that we
will use pyridoxal phosphate
in a slightly different way
to convert serine to glycine
plus a one-carbon unit
that we can use
for something else.
I don't have time
to go into them
in this introductory course,
but pyridoxal phosphate
is also involved in other
amino-acid reactions.
So last time, we
discussed ethanolamine.
And remember,
ethanolamine is an alcohol
that's found in phospholipids,
phosphatidylethanolamine.
Serine is used to
generate ethanolamine.
And pyridoxal
phosphate basically,
enables decarboxylation
of serine
to generate ethanolamine.
Serine can also be turned
into pyruvate and ammonia.
It's an alternative way
to generate ammonia.
That also involves
pyridoxal phosphate.
And if you're
interested, you can
look up these reactions
and their mechanisms
and see how pyridoxal
phosphate is repurposed
for those reactions, all right?
But for today's purposes, this
is what pyridoxal phosphate is.
This is how it allows
transamination.
And so now it
should be very clear
how it is that fish
can eat a bunch
of protein-containing
food and excrete nitrogen
into the ocean, all right?
And that is they can take
whatever, some amino acid.
They can do a
pyridoxal-phosphate-containing
transamination reaction and
generate the alpha-keto acid
with the nitrogen going
on to alpha-ketoglutarate
to generate glutamate.
This alpha-keto acid
can now be oxidized.
That's favorable.
That can be used to generate
ATP and allow the fish to get
the energy it needs to swim.
That glutamate can now
basically carry out
the glutamate-dehydrogenase
reaction, generating ammonia,
regenerating alpha-ketoglutarate
to accept the next nitrogen
to allow oxidation of the carbon
backbone in the amino acid.
And the ammonia can
float off into the ocean
where it doesn't
hurt anybody and be
fertilizer for some algae.
All right?
And so there is a way to take
catabolism of amino acids,
get energy, and excrete
the nitrogen as ammonia,
basically involving
transamination,
which requires pyridoxal
phosphate and glutamate
dehydrogenase.
All right.
Now, it turns out
tadpoles do the same thing
because they live in water.
But when a tadpole becomes a
frog or if you're a mammal,
you don't do this anymore
because now you don't have
infinite water to excrete into.
And so instead, as I
said earlier, we're
going to generate urea
as a way to excrete
nitrogen. And of course,
I mentioned earlier--
I'm not going to draw it
again, but birds and reptiles--
because you'll see making
urea requires a lot of water--
you can save even
that water by making
uric acid appearing instead.
Now, how you make
purines will be
discussed in the last lecture.
You'll see how you
make uric acid there.
But for now, I want to discuss
how we generate urea as a way--
an alternative way to deal
with amino-acid metabolism
and excrete nitrogen.
Turns out that as we discuss
how you synthesize urea also
discusses how we're going
to make and break down
arginine, one of those
exception amino acids.
And you'll see why arginine
and urea are really
tied to metabolism
in the way they are.
And so let me just remind
you what arginine looks like.
OK?
So this here is the amino
acid arginine, all right?
I'm going to redraw
part of this side chain
here in a different color.
OK?
And I did it that way
because I want to show you
how this is related to urea?
So if I take water--
taking off of that end
of the arginine molecule
generates urea, all right?
And so what we're
left with after we
do that is this
other amino acid,
which is not found in protein
but is found in metabolism.
And it is an amino
acid called ornithine.
And so basically, if you break
down arginine into ornithine,
you generate urea.
And so it should be
clear that if I can now
create a cycle where
I take ornithine,
pick up a couple of nitrogen
and regenerate arginine,
now I have a way to basically,
produce urea because then I
can cycle arginine to ornithine,
make urea, pick up two more
nitrogen, regenerate
arginine, and that's
a way to generate urea.
Now, this series of
reactions occurs via cycle
called the urea cycle.
And the urea cycle
was also described
by our old friend, Hans Krebs.
So remember, Hans Krebs
described the TCA cycle.
Turns out the urea cycle
was described by Hans Krebs
before the TCA cycle and
is really the first cycle
described.
And so part of the
inspiration for the TCA cycle
came because Hans Krebs
already had cycles on the brain
from describing
their urea cycle.
Now, it is a common
misconception
that all cells do
the urea cycle.
That is absolutely not true.
Lots of cells
carry out reactions
that involve the urea
cycle because it's also
involved in arginine
metabolism, all right?
But the urea cycle, as
we're going to describe it,
is really, at least in us,
selective for our livers
and our kidneys because this is
really the series of reactions
that we run to
net-generate urea, which
ends up in our urine.
OK?
And so remember, it would
be nitrogen transported
to the kidneys or the liver via
glutamate or glutamine and then
and end up ultimately,
entering this urea cycle
to generate urea.
Now, this involves
reactions that
will occur in multiple
compartments in the cell.
And so most of it
happens on the cytosol,
but there's one reaction that
occurs in the mitochondria.
And so a general overview
is as follows, OK?
So I just showed you how you
can start from the amino acid
arginine and generate the
non-proteinogenic amino acid
ornithine, all right?
And this will involve
production of urea, all right?
That reaction occurs
in the cytosol.
But the next reaction, which
is ornithine picking up a CO2,
as well as or anything picking
up an ammonia to generate
another non-proteinogenic
amino acid called citrulline--
this reaction occurs
in the mitochondria.
And then that citrulline will
pick up another nitrogen--
show you how it does
this in a minute--
to make a molecule
called argininosuccinate.
And then that
argininosuccinate will
be turned back into arginine.
And so a four-step cycle--
this reaction--
ornithine to citrulline
happening in the mitochondria
and then regenerating
the arginine from citrulline
in two steps happening
in the cytosol and then the
arginine-backed ornithine
in the cytosol to generate urea.
All right.
Now let's go through the
details of how this works.
And we're going to start
here and the mitochondria
at this ornithine to
citrulline reaction.
So it turns out the
first part of this
is generating a
molecule referred
to as carbamoyl phosphate.
I'll write that out in a second.
And so this comes
from CO2, which,
of course, is in equilibrium
and cells with bicarbonate, OK?
So there's bicarbonate.
Just like we saw when we did
carboxylation reactions, if I
phosphrylate the
bicarbonate with ATP,
this molecule here then
would react with biotin,
and that was a way I did
carboxylation reactions.
Well, it turns out
that rather than react
with the nitrogen on biotin,
I can also react with ammonia.
That generates this
carbamic-acid intermediate,
which can then be
phosphorylated with ATP, again,
to generate this molecule, which
is called carbamoyl phosphate.
OK, so carbamoyl phosphate.
It turns out this whole step--
two ATPs taking CO2 and
ammonia and generating
carbamoyl phosphate is carried
out by a single enzyme.
This carbamoyl
phosphate will then
react with an
ornithine molecule.
So here's ornithine.
OK.
And that will generate
this molecule,
which is the amino acid
citrulline, ornithine and
citrulline being the two
major amino acids not found
in protein.
All right, now this citrulline,
then, in the cytosol
can undergo a reaction with ATP.
And it's easier to
see if I rearrange
this part here of the
side chain of citrulline.
So I'm just here going
to draw the side chain.
So it turns out this
will react with ATP.
So I'm just going to draw ATP
here in this stylized way.
That's going to release
pyrophosphate, which can be,
of course, pulled
forward by cleaving
the pyrophosphate into two
inorganic-phosphate molecules.
And so now you have
citrulline with an AMP on it.
And that can react
with an aspartate,
the amino acid aspartate--
so this is the amino
acid aspartate--
losing the AMP to generate
this intermediate--
this intermediate, which is
called argininosuccinate.
So argininosuccinate--
why is it called that?
Because this is a
succinate molecule here.
And this part here is
an arginine molecule.
And now what can happen next?
Oh, by the way, this
reaction here from basically,
adding citrulline to
argininosuccinate-- it's
carried out by one of my
favorite enzyme names.
It's called Argininosuccinate
Synthase, abbreviated ASS.
So the enzyme is
the ASS enzyme--
A-S-S-- Argininosuccinate
Synthase--
to turn citrulline
into argininosuccinate.
Once you have
argininosuccinate, you
can now carry out that reaction,
which will generate two things.
From the purple half
here, you will now
end up with this molecule, which
is fumarate from the TCA cycle,
as well as I've regenerated one
of the most tedious amino acids
to draw, which is arginine.
So here, we have our
amino acid arginine.
OK?
And so that fumarate
now needs to be,
of course, turned
back into aspartate.
You know how to do that.
I can take fumarate,
turn it into malate.
That's adding water.
That's the TCA cycle Then
malate to oxalacetate--
that's NAD to NADH.
And then aspartate can be
transaminated into aspartate.
And you can basically see how
I can run that you urea cycle
as a way to excrete
nitrogen one,
from carbamoyl phosphate,
one from aspartate
to generate urea.
And so this complete
cycle is actually
a few cycles put together,
sometimes referred to as Krebs
bicycle, or Krebs tricycle.
And I'll just draw it out here.
So if you start with
argininosuccinate here
in the middle, that
argininosuccinate
will generate fumarate
and arginine, OK?
Arginine into ornithine will
allow generation of urea.
Ornithine can be
turned into citrulline,
picking up a carbamoyl
phosphate, which, of course, is
from CO2 plus ammonia.
That citrulline and
aspartate come together
to give you argininosuccinate.
And then that fumarate
can run via the TCA cycle
to generate malate.
So that's water.
Malate can be used to
generate oxalacetate.
So that is, of course--
OK.
That oxalacetate can be
used to generate aspartate.
That's a transamination
reaction.
So that transamination
reaction [INAUDIBLE]
glutamate to alpha-ketoglutarate
and then glutamate
to alpha-ketoglutarate.
Glutamate-dehydrogenase reaction
can bring the nitrogen in.
And so this here
complete cycle--
what you'll see is actually
balanced with respect
to both electrons because of
the glutamate-dehydrogenase
reaction and the
malate-oxalacetate direction,
as well as all the
nitrogen, really
allows you to take
nitrogen as ammonia, put it
in the system as aspartate, use
that to combine with citrulline
to make argininosuccinate.
Go to arginine, make urea
with the other nitrogens
coming from carbamoyl phosphate
to generate the citrulline.
And so the ammonia
that's brought
to the liver and the kidneys
via glutamate or glutamine
can then be incorporated
into aspartame and carbamoyl
phosphate and ultimately,
excreted as ammonia.
You can see that there's lots
of ATP that's required here.
You need two ATP here to
generate carbamoyl phosphate.
And you need
another two ATP here
at the argininosuccinate
synthase step
to generate argininosuccinate.
And you also need CO2,
but the net effect
is that you generate urea.
OK, I know that the urea
cycle is complicated.
I will start out
next time running
through another
review of it just
to make sure you have it clear.
Thank you.